is still extremely important to the history of quantum computing because it provided the spark that got others
thinking about larger, more sophisticated quantum algorithms.
This includes a multicubit extension of Deutsch's algorithm that demonstrates a much more impressive quantum advantage.
This is called the Deutsch Josa algorithm. It solves a similar problem, but in this case, the blackbox function
that we want to learn about takes n bits as an input and outputs a single bit. As
before, we're promised that the function is either constant, meaning the output bit is always one or always zero,
regardless of the input bit string, or balanced, meaning the output is zero for
half of the input bit strings and one for the other half. There are, of course, other
functions that take n bits to a single bit that are neither constant nor balanced. But in this problem, we're
promised that none of those functions are inside the black box. The one in the box is guaranteed to be either constant
or balanced. The Deutsch Joseph circuit looks similar to Deutsche's algorithm, but with more cubits. Here we have an
implementation of the Deutsch Jose algorithm to learn about a threebit function. This time we have three cubits
for the input state rather than just the one. And then we have this last cubit for the output state. As before, again
we prepare all the input cubits to be in the state 0 + one and the output cubit
to be in the state 0 minus one. Then although the math is a little more complicated to follow, the principle
remains the same. If the function is constant, it will not depend on the top three cubits at all. So their states
will transform back to zero after the second hatomards and our measurement will yield a threebit string of all
zeros. But if the function is balanced then when we measure the cubits following the hatoms the phase kickback
mechanism will cause one or more of those bits to be one. That might not be so easy to see this time but if you work
through each step yourself you'll soon see this must be the case. One way to check this is to try to calculate the
probability of measuring all zeros with a balanced function. You should get a probability of zero. Let's run the
Deutsch Josa algorithm on a quantum computer with Qiskit. The toughest step is probably creating the Deutsch Joseph
function. That will be our black box that we query here. This code produces a random Deutsch Joseph function that is
guaranteed to be either balanced or constant. Then we make our Deutsch Joseph circuit inserting our black box
function here. Again, we run the circuit with sampler and after we measure, we look at
the measured bits to determine whether the function was balanced or constant.
If they're all zero, it's constant. But if there's at least one one bit in the string, then it's balanced. In this
case, we get a bit string of 1 one one.
So, we know that the function was balanced. I hope I've given you your first glimpse at how quantum algorithms
can take advantage of interesting and often subtle quantum phenomena to obtain their advantage over classical
algorithms. You've probably also picked up on how tricky it can be to design quantum algorithms. Even the very first
one required a lot of creativity to achieve just a modest win over classical methods. And since that first algorithm,
physicists and computer scientists have continued to come up with incredibly inventive ways to use quantum mechanics
to their advantage, including further extensions and applications of the Deutsch Josa algorithm. If you want to
learn about some of these, as well as try out the Deutsch and Deutsch Josa algorithms for yourself, head over to
the module linked in the description to get started. Thanks for watching and I'll see you next time.